RADS are crawling all over the house of
the Dragon but are they just a metaphor
or something more and where have we seen
that mysterious red flower before
several weeks in a row various rodents
have scurried in and out of frame on
House of the Dragon in episode 6 for
saris spots a mouse on a mantle as he's
alone in his bed chamber as viewers see
hilarious tell Queen Allison's about the
weakness of children but the most
diverse inclusion of a rat is the one
that drinks a recently deceased sir
Joffrey lombust blood as rhaenyra and
Lenor exchanged their vowels in episode
5. many readers of Fire and Blood feel
like the rats are an indicator of an
upcoming plotline that's if the show
follows the book would be a huge spoiler
so we'll say no more about that here but
King's landing's prominent Vermin
problem might have another explanation
though there's no textual evidence for
this theory in George R.R Martin's
writing red is moderator and YouTuber
Joe magician has laid out the
possibility that a character on House of
the Dragon could be a skin changer like
Bran Stark if so the rats could be being
used to spy and gather information
10 years on it seems like every move
mortal enemies princess rhaenyra and
queen Alison to make is a power play
episode 6 opens with rhaenyra's delivery
of her third child just about the
moments the Midwife places the baby in
the princess's arms a messenger arrives
to take the newborn to the Queen's
Chambers rhaenyra will not have her son
separated from her so quickly before
she's even past the placenta she dresses
to make the long walk through the red
keep her husband Lena valorian
accompanies her and holds her upright as
she has to stop each time she has an
after-birth contraction during one of
these moments on the stairs Lord Caswell
and his lady wife approach rhaenyra and
Lenor enthusiastically if I may be of
any service
today May it come my Lord
this seems like a subtle bit of
foreshadowing on the show's part as
prominent families begin to take sides
house Caswell appears to be staunchly
loyal to rhaenyra as tension and
uncertainty about the succession mounts
and that loyalty will likely soon be
tested in dramatic fashion
after anira Wills herself to the Queen's
private quarters she presents a newborn
Prince to Allison who's basically become
her evil stepmother and her father King
viserys who shockingly still alive
though just barely a series is genuinely
happy to meet the child and remarks that
he thinks a boy has his father's nose
when the queen asks what they'll call
him when Nero begins to say that they
haven't decided but then Lenor burst out
the name Joffrey which probably made
Game of Thrones fans perk up but the
name is a reference to another murderer
Joffrey from nearly two centuries prior
and Alison can't hide her feelings about
her it's an unusual name for a valerian
with this polite enough sounding
comments Alison's is actually making two
accusations though we only met him
briefly Joffrey was the first name of
lenor's lover sir Joffrey lammuth the
Knight of kisses who was brutally
murdered by Sir Kristen Cole at the
welcome feast in episode 5. Lenor and
Joffrey's relationship wasn't open
Secret at least a drift Mark and
probably even at King's Landing still
for the queen to underscore the fact
that the Future King consort once the
name his purported son after his
murdered boyfriend is remarkably bold
Allison is also implying that she knows
this child like the previous two isn't
really Lanos since she's well aware of
his sexual preferences do you keep
trying Selena
soon I'll let you make it what it looks
like you
think that Sarah says small Council has
changed considerably over the years
coreless valorian has been replaced by
Thailand Lannister as master of ships
when Otto Hightower was dismissed as
hand of the king Lionel strong was
chosen to fulfill that most important
role only Lyman beesberry remains in his
original position of Master of coin but
two of the most notable changes to the
king's Council are the addition of his
daughter princess rhaenyra and his wife
Queen Alison rhaenyra was promoted from
Cut Bearer to council member after being
named air and Princess of Dragonstone a
decade later a much more politically
active Allison also has a seat at the
table production designers conceived of
small spheres to signify a character's
Presence at the small Council table each
in colors that represent the great
houses to which the council members
belong Queen Alison sits behind a green
ball that's reminiscent of hightower's
colors and her Infamous gown while
rhaenyra rolls her fingers across a
black one for House Targaryen these
totems demonstrate that both of
accumulated immense power in the last
decade regardless of their opposition to
each other earlier in the season it was
frowned upon for the princess to speak
at all when she's with the Lords behind
the closed doors of the small Council
room now she and Alison are practically
running the show though they seem to
disagree about everything
we met line was strong CERN Harwin and
Laris during the hunt in episode 3 Lara
assassins ingratiated himself to Queen
Alison by becoming her an official
master of Whisperers while Harwin has
entangled himself in some deadly serious
Palace Drama by fathering my nearest
three children Savvy viewers would have
noticed that Harwin was quite taken with
rhaenyra after she killed the boar and
when she donned boys clothing on the
street of silk he's also the one that
carries her to safety after the melee at
the welcome Feast lyrics doesn't seem to
have a very high opinion of his father
the hand or his brother when Queen
Alison's complains that King viserys
wouldn't accept Lionel's resignation
after Harwin attacks her Kristen in the
training yard Laris graduates from
Whispers to action Lionel takes Harwin
to the family seat of harrenhal which is
said to be cursed to avoid persistent
rumors of the prince's parentage
meanwhile lares frees some of King's
landing's most dangerous prisoners so
long as they're okay with him cutting
off their tongues so they can't spill
the beans he sends his assassins to
harrenhall to murder his father and
brother via arson which he tells a
horrified Allison that she'll thank him
for later as he holds the foreign flower
to which he previously compared her an
outsider
among the natives
in Fire and Blood lyrics isn't Just
Master of Whisperers he's Lord Confessor
that title is a euphemism for torture in
Chief so it's no surprise to book
readers that he's so eager to break out
the tools of his trade
[Music]